สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครู
เรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนวันนี้เจอกันวันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้
เจอกันวันพุธค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมอือืปีพ.ศ
อะไรค่ะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูป๊าตอนนี้เวลา 14
น 13
นาที 14 น 13 นแล้วค่ะทุกคนใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
คะเรียมเห็นเสื้อครูฟ้าน่ารัก
มากใช่ไหมมเป็นอะโวคาโดนะคะ
เหรอเสื้อ
อะโวคาโดเสื้ออะโวคาโดค่ะเป็นเสื้อ
อะโวคาโดครูชอบใส่เสื้ออะโวคาโดนะคะอุ้ย
น่ารักมากอืใช่แล้วูฟ้ามีหลายตัวมยคะ
เสื้อ
อะโวคาโดคูณฟ้ามีแค่ตัวเดียวค่ะครูเรียม
มีเสื้ออะโวคาโดแค่ 1 ตัวอืซื้อนิดหน่อยอ
หรอแล้วครูฟ้าแบบมีเสื้อลายอื่นอีกใช่
มยเสื้อลายอื่นมีค่ะก็มีเสื้อลายอื่นๆอัน
นี้ลายอะโวคาโดใช่มยแล้วก็มีเสื้อลาย
แอปเปิ้ลเสื้อลายบลูเบอร์รี่ทำไมครูฟา
เป็นมิสผลไม้เหรอคะไม่รู้เสื
ชอบเสื้อูฟ้าที่แบบมีลายต่างๆแต่ว่าของ
เรียมก็แบบเป็นเสื้อแบบเสื้อยืดแบบเนี้ย
แต่ว่ามีสี
ขาวสีขาวสี
ชมพูมีสีอะไรอีกอ่ะสี
น้ำเงินกำลังหาสีน้ำเงินเนี่ยหาสี
น้ำเงินมีแบบเสื้อยืดแต่ว่ามีหลายๆสี
อืครูเรียมครูเรียมไม่อยากใส่เสื้อเอา
โวคาโดเหรอคะดิมก็แบบไม่เคยคิดไม่เคยคิด
จะใส่เสื้อ
อะโวคาโดแต่ว่าคิดแค่แบบใส่เสื้อยืด
ธรรมดานะอืใช่แล้วก็คิดว่าซื้อบ่อยด้วยนะ
เสื้อยืดแบบเนี้ยแต่แบบสีขาวสีขาวเห็น
เสื้อยืดสีขาวก็แบบ
ชอบต้องซื้อค่ะหูฟ้าครูเรียมชอบซื้อเสื้อ
เสื้อสีขาวหรอใช่ค่ะเสื้อสีขาวใส่ไปแล้ว
มันก็แบบเวลาเอามือไปจับมันก็
แบบสกปรกแล้วอ่ะมันจะเป็น
แบบใช่เสื้อสีขาวเนะคะนักเรียนท่ามือนัก
เรียนเนี่ยอืไม่สะอาดแล้วนักเรียนจับ
เสื้อื้อืๆืเสื้อสีขาวก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็น
เสื้อสีดำนะคะใช่หรือว่าใส่เสื้อสีขาวไป
แบบสักพักนึงสีขาวก็จะเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนเป็น
สีเหลืองอ่ะอืสีเหลืองๆแบบเนี้ยอืใช่เสี
เหลืองก็ต้องซื้อใหม่อีกค่ะครูฟ้าครู
เรียมจะไปซื้อใหม่หรอเรมจะไปซื้อเสื้อที่
ไหนเรมก็ซื้อออนไลน์ไงซื้อออนไลน์
ใช่ซื้อของออนไลน์ตอนเนี้ยเรียมก็เลยคิด
ว่าเรียมซื้อของออนไลน์แบบกดดูในโทรศัพท์
น่ะมากขึ้นใช้เวลาช้อปปิ้งซื้อของออนไลน์
มากขึ้นอือืครูเรียมเนี่ยชอบซื้อของ
ออนไลน์นะคะแล้วก็มันจะมีแอปพลิเคชันเนาะ
นักเรียน shopee
Lazada เป็นการช้อปปิ้งนะคะซื้อของ
ออนไลน์ใช่ค่ะิมก็เลยไปดูใน Google ว่า
มันจะมีเช็คลิสสำหรับคนที่ติดการซื้อของ
ออนไลน์จริงหรอเช็คลิสคืออะไรอ่ะเช็คลิส
แบบที่มีข้อ 1 คนที่ชอบซื้อของออนไลน์จน
แบบแย่มากๆแล้วอ่ะอืแล้วก็จะมีข้อ 2 ตึดๆ
ๆๆๆเป็นยังไงบ้างที่แบบชอบซื้อของออนไลน์
ที่แบบทำให้เราแย่มากๆแล้วอ๋อวันนี้ครู
เรียมก็เลยมีคำถามใช่มั้ยคะใช่เรียมก็มา
ถามตัวเองแล้วก็จะได้ถามครูฟ้าและถามนัก
เรียนทุกคนด้วยนักเรียนด้วยนะคะนักเรียน
ลองเช็คดูนะคะว่านักเรียนเนี่ยชอบซื้อของ
ออนไลน์
มยใช่ค่ะอืเรามาดูกันข้อ
1 ข้อที่ 1 นะคะข้อที่ 1 ว่ายังไงคะครู
เรียมคำถามคำถามมีอยู่ว่า
เออมันไม่ใช่คำถามอ่ะเนาะให้เรานึกนึกว่า
การการช้อปปิ้งซื้อของออนไลน์เนี่ยเราคิด
ถึงการซื้อของอยู่ตลอดเวลา
มยแบบคิดถึงการซื้อของตลอดเวลาหรอใช่
สมมุติว่าครูฟ้านั่งทำงานอยู่ครูฟ้าก็คิด
ว่าวันนี้ครูฟ้าจะช้อปปิ้งอะไรหรือว่าครู
ฟ้ากินข้าวครูฟ้าก็คิดครูฟ้าจะซื้อของ
ออนไลน์อะไรดีนะอาบน้ำครูฟ้าก็คิดว่าครู
ฟ้าจะช้อปปิ้งดีมยูฟ้าต้องเข้าแอป shopee
L  Lazada ไปซื้อของซื้อของอันนี้คือเรา
คิดถึงเรื่องการซื้อของ
ออนไลน์ตลอดเวลา 24 ชมงมั้ยคะะใช่ๆค่ะ
แล้วก็แบบจนเข้านอนจะนอนแล้วก็แบบ
เฮ้ยหยิบโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมามาแล้วก็ดูเช็คซิ
เออเอ๊จะซื้ออะไรดีนะจะซื้ออะไรดีนะแล้ว
ก็จนนอนหลับไปอันนั้นคือข้อที่ 1 ที่เรา
อาจจะชอบซื้อของออนไลน์มากๆแบบมากจนแบบ
แย่แล้วอ่ะอือือๆ
อือันนี้เนี่ยก็คือให้เรา
ทำอะไรสำหรับเรียมก็ไม่นะไม่ได้คิดถึง
ซื้อของออนไลน์ 24 ชมมนะสำหรับเรียมไม่
ใช่สำหรับครูฟ้า
ล่ะครูฟ้าไม่ได้คิดถึงการซื้อของออนไลน์
24 ชมครับเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่
กินนะฮะซื้อของออนไลน์นี่รวมเรื่องกิน
มั้ยคะไม่ใช่นะไม่เกี่ยวกันนะคะนักเรียน
ช้อปปิ้งออนไลน์เนี่ยไม่ใช่ก็คือการซื้อ
ของใช่มยแล้วของของก็มาส่งจริงๆครูฟ้า
เพิ่งซื้อของออนไลน์ไปนะคะเป็นครีมนะคะ
ของเพิ่งมาถึงนี่คือครีมที่ครูฟ้าซื้อ
ออนไลน์ไปนะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าไม่ได้ซื้อบ่อย
ๆไงครูฟ้าก็เลยไม่คิดถึงการซื้อของ
ออนไลน์ไม่คิดถึงบ่อยๆอืม
อืนั่นละค่ะเดี๋ยวเราไปแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะ
เป็นยังไงบ้างคิดถึงการซื้อของแบบ 24 ชมง
มใช่นักเรียนซื้อของออนไลน์ตลอดเวลามยกิน
ข้าวก็คิดวันนี้ซื้ออะไรอาบน้ำก็คิดวัน
นี้ซื้ออะไรซักผ้าก็คิดเอช้อปปิ้งอะไร
ซื้ออะไรอันนี้นะคะนักเรียนถ้าใช่นัก
เรียนก็เริ่มติดการซื้อของออนไลน์ใช่มใช่
ๆติดก็คือแบบทำมากๆอ่ะทำบางสิ่งบางอย่าง
มากๆมากจนแบบมากเกินไปแล้วแบบไม่ดีอืออือ
อืใช่ค่ะโอเคมาดูข้อที่ 2 ข้อที่ 2 ก็คือ
หยุดซื้อของออนไลน์ไม่
ได้หยุดซื้อของออนไลน์ไม่ได้เป็นยังไง
อย่างเช่นเราแบบไม่มีเงินแล้วมีเงินอยู่
20 บาทแต่ว่าก็แบบอยากได้มากอ่ะอยากได้
ได้มากค่ะครูฟ้าเรียมอยากได้กระเป๋าอ่ะ
เรียมอยากได้กระเป๋าเรียมอยากได้กระเป๋า
อะไรใช่อยากได้กระเป๋าแบบนี้อีก 1 ใบแต่
ว่าไม่มีเงินค่ะครูฟ้าเรียมแบบครูฟ้าครู
ฟ้าจ่ายให้เรียมก่อนได้มยจ่ายให้ครูเรียม
ก่อนใช่หยุดไม่ได้แบบหยุดช้อปปิ้งไม่ได้
ใช่ค่ะก็คือการที่นักเรียนอาจจะซื้อของ
ออนไลน์ทุกทุกวันใช่มยวันนี้ซื้อแล้ว
พรุ่งนี้ก็ซื้ออีกแล้วก็ซื้อทุกวันทุกวัน
ทุกวันนะฮะใช่นี้คือหยุดไม่ได้แล้วอใช่
แล้วก็ซื้อของของมาส่งเรียมก็บอกครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าจ่ายเงินให้ให้หน่อยอืตอนนี้เรียม
แบบไม่มีเงินโอได้ค่ะครูเรียมเดี๋ยวครู
ฟ้าจ่ายเงินให้ก่อนแล้วครูเรียมค่อยเอา
เงินมาคืนครูฟ้านะคะใช่อันนั้นคือข้อที่ 2
ที่บอกว่าเราเนี่ยติด
ช้อปปิ้งมากๆแล้วคือแบบแย่แล้วอ่ะอืๆอื
คุณังเป็นมยตอนนี้หรอยังไม่เป็นอุ๊ยดี
แล้วค่ะใช่แล้วนะคะอแต่ตอนนี้แบบคิดว่า
เออซื้อแบบมากขึ้นแล้ว
แหละเออใช่ก็เลยต้องขึ้นต้องดูในลิสต์นี้
หลายคนอาจจะเป็นแล้วนะแล้วก็สำหรับข้อที่
3 ข้อที่ 3 ก็คือรู้สึก
แบบรู้สึกหงุดหงิด
ยังไงอ่ะรู้สึก
แบบ
เฮ้ยดูแล้วแบบอยากได้เสื้อไซส S อ่ะแต่
มันไม่มีอ่ะครูฟ้ามันมี ML แล้วเรียมก็
แบบอยากได้อ่ะอืแต่มันไม่มีทำยังไงดีก็
ไม่รู้แต่แบบเนี่ยตอนนี้แบบไม่แฮปปี้เลย
ตอนเนี้ยอืม
คือรู้สึกพอไม่ได้ซื้อของออนไลน์ใช่มั้ย
คะนักเรียนก็จะรู้สึกหงุดหงิด
อืหงุดหงิดอารมณ์ไม่ดีหงุดหงิดโกรธอะไร
ประมาณนั้นนะคะเวลาที่ไม่ได้ซื้อของ
ออนไลน์นักเรียนโกรธ
มยหงุดหงิดหรรือเปล่า
อืครูฟ้ามีมั้ยไม่เพราะว่าครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
ช้อปปิ้งอยู่แล้วหรือเปล่าใช่ค่ะครูฟ้า
ไม่ชอบช้อปปิ้งเท่าไหร่เอครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
ไม่ค่อยซื้อของ
ออนไลน์ก็มีซื้อของออนไลน์บ้างแต่ครูฟ้า
ไม่ได้ซื้อของออนไลน์บ่อยๆนะคะนานๆซื้อ
ที่ที 2 เดือนก็ซื้อของออนไลน์ 1 ครั้ง
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยพอดีว่ามันมีโปรโมชั่นครู
ฟ้าก็เลยซื้อครีมมาเยอะเห็นมั้ยเพราะว่า
ครูฟ้าซื้อเยอะนะคะแล้วครูฟ้าก็ไม่ซื้อ
อีกอืซื้อแบบเยอะๆไป
เลยนั่นแหละูฟ้าก็เลยไม่รู้สึกโกรธหรือ
ว่าหงุดหงิดเวลาที่ไม่ได้ซื้อของออนไลน์
อืว่าโอเคค่ะแฮปปี้ดีแต่เรียมแบบมาดูข้อ
ที่ 4 สิคะครูฟ้าทำไมคะข้อที่ 4 บอก
ว่าใช้เงินใช้เงินเกินจากที่คิดไว้ว่าจะ
ช้อปปิ้งใช้เงินเกินกว่าที่คิดไว้เป็นยัง
ไงคะครูเรียมใช่ค่ะอย่างเช่นวันนี้ใช่มย
คะเรียมคิดว่าเรียมจะใช้เงินแค่ 200 บาทเ
เรียมดูอันนี้
ก่อนออเสียวันนี้คิดว่าจะใชใช้เงิน 200
บาทแต่ว่าพอเห็นแบบเลื่อนดูในโทรศัพท์ก็
เฮ้ยหมวกอ่ะหมวกอยากได้หมวกก็แบบ
250 ออุยแบบหรืออะไรอีกอ่ะอยากได้หูฟัง
อ่ะอยากได้หูฟังอีกอันนึงก็แบบเท่าไหร่
อ่ะ 500
อืวันนี้คิดว่าจะใช้เงิน 250 แบบ 200 บาท
อืไ้ 200 บาทแต่ว่าก็ใช้เงินเกินไปแล้ว
อ่ะอืเกินไปประมาณ 550 บาทอืใช้เงินเกิน
ไป 550 บาทใช่ค่ะนักเรียนจริงๆเวลานัก
เรียนซื้อของเราจะมีลิมิตของเราใช่มั้ยคะ
ว่าจะใช้เงินกี่บาทแต่ถ้าช้อปปิ้ง
ช้อปปิ้งช้อปปิ้งเนี่ยแล้วนักเรียนเพลิน
น่ะเราบอกช้อปปิ้งเพลินนักเรียนอาจจะซื้อ
ของมากเกินกว่าเงินที่เราลิมิไว้
อืใช่อันนี้ก็ไม่ได้เดมก็เลยคิดว่าข้อ 4
นี่แหละที่เรียมแบบเฮ้ยจริง
ด้วยใช้เงินเกินมากกว่าที่คิดไว้อือันนี้
ครูฟ้าไม่มีลิมิตอยู่แล้วนะคะเวลา
ช้อปปิ้งหรอมันก็เลยเกินบ่อยๆนะคะว่าใช้
เงินเยอะในการช้อปปิ้ง 1 ครั้งก็ไม่เยอะ
มากแต่ว่ามันก็ก็ก็รู้สึกเหมือนว่าเออมัน
เยอะเนาะออก็เลยข้อนี้ครูฟ้าเป็นนะข้อที่
4 ใช่มยข้อที่ 4 ูฟ้าใช้เเกินนะคะอืแล้ว
ก็มีข้อที่ 5 อีกค่ะครูฟ้าข้อที่ 5 ใช่
ข้อที่ 5 เขาบอกว่าใช้เวลา
ใช้เวลากับการทำอย่างอื่นๆน่ะน้อย
ลงยังไงอ่ะเหมือนเรียมเคยอ่านหนังสือใช่
มั้ยเรียม
ชอบชอบอ่านหนังสืออืิมก็อ่านๆๆๆๆแต่ตอน
นี้ใช้
เวลาอ่านหนังสือน้อยลงอือแล้วเอาเวลาไปทำ
อะไรเอาเวลามา
ดูโทรศัพท์เ้ยสวยอ่ะสวยก็แบบเฮ้ยอยากได้
อ่ะแบบเนี้ยเอาเวลามาซื้อของออนไลน์แทนนะ
คะแทนการอ่านหนังสืออุ้ยครูไฟ้ายังไม่
เป็นนะคะเพราะว่าครูฟ้ายังเล่นเกมกินนอน
เยอะๆอยู่นะคะอันนี้ครูฟ้าไม่เป็นใช่โห
ยอดเยี่ยมมากเรมก็เห็นว่าเมื่อก่อนเรมออก
กำลังกายแบบประมาณ 1 ชมง 2 ชมงใช่มยตอน
นี้ก็ออกกำลังกายน้อยลง
อืแต่ก็คิดอยู่นะว่า
เอ๊เราเอาเวลาไปช้อปปิ้งหรือเปล่าใช่ครู
เรียมครูเรียมเอาเวลาไปช้อปปิ้งหรือเปล่า
คะนึว่าเปล่านะ
[เพลง]
นอนไม่น่าจะเกี่ยวแล้วใช่่มยคูปใช่ๆค่ะ
นอนนอนก็ไม่ก็โอเคนะอะไรเราทำอะไรที่ไม่
ได้ไปช้อปปิ้งออนไลน์อ่ะมันก็โอเคค่ะอื
อืแล้วมาดูข้อข้อนี้ดีกว่าค่ะข้อที่
6 ข้อที่ 6 เขาบอกว่าเราจะซื้อของที่
แบบไม่จำเป็นบ่อย
ๆซื้อของที่ไม่จำเป็นบ่อยๆครูฟ้ากำลังทำ
อยู่นะคะเอครูฟ้าไม่ได้ซื้อของออนไลน์
บ่อยๆแต่ครูฟ้าซื้อของที่ไม่จำเป็นนะคะ
นักเรียนของที่ไม่จำเป็นก็คือของที่นัก
เรียนไม่ต้องมีก็โอเคนักเรียนไม่ต้องซื้อ
ก็ได้อย่างอันนี้นะคะครีมเอ่อครูฟ้าซื้อ
ครีมเป็นโลชั่นมาแต่จริงๆครูฟ้ามีโลชั่น
อยู่ที่บ้าน 5 ขวดแล้วนะคะโหแล้วฟ้าก็
เพิ่งซื้อขวดที่ 6  7  8  9 มาูฟ้าอันนี้
คือไม่จำเป็นนะนักเรียนเพราะครูฟ้ามี
โลชั่นอยู่แล้วแต่มันเป็นโปรโมชั่นนะคะ
นักเรียนครู้าก็เลยซื้อมาเห็นมยอันนี้คือ
ของไม่จำเป็นแบบอืเราไม่มีก็โอเคอ่ะนะคะ
นักเรียนอืลองเช็คดูว่านัก
เรียนสไม่จำใช่ๆแต่สำหรับเรียมนะของที่
ไม่จำเป็นที่เรียมซื้อก็คือแบบแบบพวง
กุญแจอ่ะอันเนี้ยอันนี้กุญแจใช่มยอืกุญแจ
ก็จะมีพวง
กุญแจิมก็จะแบบเฮ้ยมีพวงกุญแจอยู่แล้วแต่
ก็คิดเฮ้สวยก็ซื้อพวงกุญแจก็แบบเฮ้ยพวง
กุญแจซื้อพวงกุญแจก็แบบซื้อพวงกุญแจบ่อยๆ
ใช่เราต้องมีพวงกุญแจพวงกุญแจพวงกุญแจ
หลายๆอันมั้ยครูฟ้าเราไม่ต้องมีหลายๆ
อันใช่นั่นแหละเรียมก็เลยคิด
โหใช่ๆเรียมซื้อของที่ไม่จำเป็นไม่มีก็
ยังโอเคแต่เรียมก็ซื้อใช่ค่ะครูเรียมออ
อันนี้ไม่ได้นะใช่ๆไม่ได้ียมก็เลยแบบเออ
โอเคมี 2 ข้อและจาก 6 ข้ออือื
เราไปดูข้อต่อไปมั้ยคะเหลือเวลามั้ยหรือ
หมดแล้วแต่ครูคิดว่าน่าจะใกล้หมดเวลาคิด
ว่าออคิดว่าเดี๋ยวเอาอีกข้อนึงดีกว่าได้
ค่ะครูเรความจริงมันมีอยู่ 10 ข้อแต่เรา
ไปที่ 7 ข้อข้อที่ 7 ก็คือมีคนบอก
ว่าอือซื้อ
ของมากเกินไปแล้ว
อืมีคนบอกนะใช่ค่ะต้องลองเช็คดูกับคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่หรือว่าภรรยาสามีแฟนของนักเรียนถ้า
นักเรียนมีแฟนใช่มยมีพี่มีน้องถ้าเกิดคน
ใกล้ๆตัวบอกว่าซื้อของมากเกินไปก็ก็แปล
ว่าเราซื้อของมากเกินไปนะคะเราต้องเบรค
ตัวเองใช่มยใช่เหมือนตอนที่เรียมอยู่ที่
บ้านน่ะก็จะมีคนแบบเอากล่องมาส่งให้ที่
บ้านอแม่ก็จะบอกซื้อของอีกแล้วหรอ
อืซื้อของอีกแล้วหรอซื้อแบบทุกวันทุกวัน
ทุกวันเลยนะไม่ดีนะอืใช่เออนิวก็เลยแบบ
เออมีคนบอกและว่าซื้อของมากเกินไปอืมนี่
ก็คือการเช็คนะคะนักเรียนเช็คลิสว่านัก
เรียนติดการช้อปปิ้งออนไลน์หรือเปล่าหรือ
ว่าติดการซื้อของออนไลน์หรือเปล่าใช่มย
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่ามีใครที่แบบอยู่ใกล้ๆนัก
เรียนเป็นเพื่อนหรือว่าเป็นสามี
ภรรยาที่แบบอติดการซื้อของออนไลน์หรือ
เปล่าที่เราคุยกันมาใน 7 ข้อนี้อ่ะมีใคร
ที่มีทั้ง 7 ข้อนี้บ้างอืมนักเรียนลองไป
เช็คดูนะคะคะแล้วก็วันนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลา
แล้วเดี๋ยวครูฟ้ากับครูเรียมไปก่อนแล้ว
เจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะใช่ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย